pumill GMA used to clean houses for a
living earning only $25 a month then 20
years ago she started farming cannabis
deep in the mountains in the north of is
watini formerly known as swasiland she
now earns 30 times what she used to
that's enough to support herself and her
family including her children and
grandchildren cannabis is commonly known
as swasi gold farming it is illegal but
it's how thousands of people here make a
living they include Z's father before
her I now have a house and it's farming
cannabis that allows me to send my kids
to school but it's becoming difficult to
Farm These
Days pum wants the government to
legalize cannabis farming and provide
support that way she and other Farmers
would no longer have to farm in secret
and hide from the police the government
has proposed a new law to allow it for
research and medicinal use but a license
would cost more than 50
$50,000 and those without it would be
fined heavily critics say this will only
benefit the country's Elite and not
smallscale Farmers the Cannabis
Association says the country's climate
is ideal for the plant and this natural
resource is farmed in almost all rural
areas we want to Lobby the new MPS into
understanding that there is need to
legalize Canabis Inland not what we saw
in the first the kind proposal that was
sent to Parliament where we feel it be
exclusive if you have exorbitant license
fees it means you are excluding the
ordinary sasi who actually lives on
cannabis cannabis remains a dangerous
business and it's transported undercover
this is matapa south of the capital in
babani it's an industrial Town that's
used as a Transit point for the movement
of the Cannabis farmed around the
country and this is where trucks collect
Consignments of cannabis and smuggle it
into neighboring South Africa
there's no official data on how much
marijuana is formed in istini but it's
estimated to be worth millions of dollar
and it's part of a global market
reported to be valued at nearly $60
billion while the new laws being
discussed in Parliament farmers are
continuing to push for it to be
legalized pumzilla is among them relying
on a trade she knows well to support
herself and create jobs in a country
where one in four people don't have work
famida Miller Al jazer
istini make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer